[Music]
welcome to Gear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc thanks for joining us in
another biscuit from the road today not
from the round table of dim lighting
Bret we have we are at VidCon and we're
actually talking with one of the
founders of VidCon also New York Times
bestselling author and one half of the
vlog brothers John Green now I was so
excited to have this conversation with
John as excited as I've been to talk to
anybody on here biscuits not just
because he was recently named one of the
100 most influential people in the world
in the world linked by Time magazine not
just because not just by you know he's
influential in my life but one top 100
in the world
and this is on ear biscuits link this is
happening on your biscuits not just
because of that not just he's been a
friend for a long time and we've always
looked up to the vlogbrothers and what
he and Hank do on the Internet not just
because he's got a book The Fault in Our
Stars that has been on the New York
Times bestsellers list for over two
years it's been at number one for over
two years and then he's got a movie that
as at the time we're recording this it's
made over a hundred million dollars the
movie based on his novel that was
adapted to fall in our stars well then
why are you excited I'm just super
excited about we want you to be excited
but I'm excited for him and I was
excited to talk about all of these
things that are happening all the
success that he's experiencing and the
way that YouTube is such an integral
part in him getting there just to get
back to the Fault in Our Stars if you
don't know much about it the plot
follows two teenagers who fall deeply in
love
after meeting ass at a Cancer Support
Group here's a clip what's your name
hazel what's your full name hazel grace
Lancaster
what are you looking at me like that
because you're beautiful oh my god let's
go watch a movie huh
um I'm free later this week coming now
you could be an ax murderer there's
always that possibility and you might
know before the success of The Fault in
Our Stars and probably even a bigger
part of what John is all about is what
he does with his brother Hank the
vlogbrothers and these guys have been an
inspiration to us they've essentially
started back in January of 2007 with
something they called Brotherhood 2.0
which consisted of daily back-and-forth
vlogs that community communicated with
each other through vlogs they say we're
not going to texting haven't any texting
but we're gonna communicate with each
other every single day email for a year
back and forth right and then if if they
didn't meet the requirement of making
their video for that day they had to
undergo a physical punishment that they
agreed upon earlier and they did it for
the whole year after the year was up
they continued and they changed the
frequency oh man they still do them to
this day when you watch the videos
they're addressing each other as well as
their fan base the nerdfighters good
morning Hank it's Sunday it's news day
and the news around here is that my
house is a construction zone and most of
the electricity is turned off and we
don't have any place to sleep and
unrelated to the incredibly expensive
home renovation my basement flooded on
Friday so now I have to take out all the
carpet and fixing it is gonna cost a
billion dollars and I'm cranky
and when I get cranky I put Willy and
his tiny elephant costume and of course
they've gone on to just a crazy amount
of success on the Internet there they
call their fans the nerdfighters and
there's a lot of them out there they
have an amazing community they started a
project for awesome
they started the foundation to decrease
worldsuck they started VidCon you know
the the green brothers have done all
kinds of things and then we find in this
conversation we're finding John and a
really interesting time where he's
experiencing he's in the midst of
experiencing this amazing success with
The Fault in Our Stars but he's also
still doing every other thing that he's
always done and so we talked to him
about what it's like what did to be in
the midst of this right I love the quote
here I think this is an association with
Time magazine's list of 100 most
influential people
actress shailene woodley from The Fault
in Our Stars is quoted as saying some
say that through his books John gives a
voice to teenagers I humbly disagree I
think John hears the voices of teenagers
he acknowledges the intelligence and
vulnerability that stem from those
beautiful years when we were for the
first time discovering the world in
ourselves outside of our familiar
familial stories but he doesn't just
listen to young adults he treats every
human he meets as their own planet
rather than simply one of his moons he
sees people with curiosity compassion
grace and excitement and he's
encouraging a huge community of
followers to do the same what a gift to
be alive at the same time as this
admirable leader and what a gift to have
this conversation
I was really fun yeah so here it is are
your biscuit with John Green you were
just telling me you're like coming off a
marathon and I don't know you're not at
a finish line but VidCon is usually the
crazy time of year but putting in
perspective of everything that's been
happening to you and your family yeah if
it calls great but yeah it feels
downright relaxing yeah you know I'm
happy to be here but but I am very
excited for Sunday we're going on my
wife and kids and I are going on
vacation and that'll be really nice so
oh yeah nice and we're just gonna really
just have some downtime as much as we
can
how old are the kids now four and one
that's it that's not a vacation it's
it's but it's um it's just a different
kind of stress yeah okay but a really
welcome kind of stress yeah you're right
it's not it's not properly relaxing mine
are ten and five now and that's just now
getting to the point where it could be
considered a vacation yeah yeah so
there's no time to go I just I I'm
excited for when they're both potty
trained that's gonna be amazing
well hopefully one is now yo yeah yeah
he's great he's great
well let me ask you how's your shoulder
no it's better I got a cortisone shot
I am I injured my shoulder playing Fifa
which is very embarrassing it what was
the diagnosed
when you went to the doctor I went to
the doctor I initially lied to the
doctor and I told the doctor that I'd
been throwing my kid up in the air Oh
because I couldn't bring myself to tell
him the truth that I had been playing
Fifa but he was playing a video game he
was like there was he was like three
your fists in the air you're celebrating
tonight and I badly injured my right
shoulder and he was like so you had some
resistance when you when you injured it
and I was like not really and it was
like you're like you're pushing up your
kid now he's like well all right fine I
was playing a video game and I raised my
arms in triumph and I felt my right arm
pop and it really hurt and the doctor
was like oh well that's it completely
now I yeah you need to be honest with me
these details are important yeah it
turns out so anyway I got a cortisone
shot it worked really well and we'll
have to kind of wait and see on the
long-term effects of me throwing my
hands in the air after well playing Fifa
I mean because you you're gonna think of
it every time you score going FIFA now
oh yeah no they're consciously you're
gonna tense aw I don't celebrate anymore
and I think it's made me a worse player
so you're just kind of just you just
sort of just sit in that the afterglow
of a goal yeah I just trying to I just
try to enjoy it quietly now he's a very
pensive FIFA player yeah yeah forgive me
for for reaching for a connection here
but is there some analogy I'm wondering
if there's analogy between all the
success of the book in the movie and
just it's phenomenal what's happening
and I'm so excited and it's it's amazing
but is there an Associated injury with
this celebration was this self-inflicted
that's a good analogy I mean I
definitely I definitely think that any
any kind of dramatic change in your life
even if it's a really positive change is
stressful like you know moving is is
stressful getting man getting married is
stressful having a kid is stressful
these are all wonderful wonderful things
like it's some of the best stuff that
that can happen to you but it's also
kind of overwhelming and this this
experience has been totally overwhelming
and at times at times really
really
restful even though it's been also
joyful and you know uh it's about the
best book to movie experience you could
possibly have to be proud of the movie
to have the movie do well to have been
included in the process all of that
stuff just really doesn't happen to
authors very often so and you kind of
built you kind of built that in because
you weren't jumping at the chance to for
it to be adapted into a movie if it
wasn't gonna be with certain
stipulations right right you're just
hungry please make please make this into
a movie yeah I know I've been in a
position where I had to be hungry before
and that does make you a lot less
discerning and this time I wasn't hungry
I didn't really want to see a movie made
of this book initially because it's so
personal to me and I just didn't think
they could anyone could really do a good
job I thought that it would be sort of
schlocky and I think they really
succeeded in staying true to the tone of
the book now most of that was luck but
some of it was kind of waiting for the
right people to come around because you
didn't direct the film you guys say it's
luck yeah well it's not my movie it's
Joshua's movie so right and you know
ultimately I didn't pick Josh I wish I
could take credit for that but the
producers of the movie pick Josh I mean
I you know saw his movie and talked to
him before he was hired but yeah
everyone else did a great job I did very
little now are you are you having a good
time are you enjoying the process yeah I
enjoyed I enjoyed like going to the
premiere so much and I we had a we had a
showing in Indianapolis that was just
with family and friends and people
who've kind of helped us along the way
of writing the book and then making the
movie you know just whether like by
babysitting for our kids or whatever and
that was really special to have you know
200 people in a room all of whom you
care about all of whom helped make this
possible and to be able to watch the
movie with them was really really
special but isn't it kind of a challenge
when I mean so many people in their
lives they're they dream of one thing
and I mean you tell me but I would
assume that there's just been a number
of dreams come true for you at this
point like whoa everything is falling
into place
but with that
experience is there this well it it's
not as good as I thought it would now
that I've got these dreams and they've
kind of lined up in a row or is it not
all it's cracked up to be is it still a
grass is greener is it I think that's
the question behind are you are you
enjoying it overall or is it actually
very difficult to enjoy it because of
all the other pressures that are coming
on as well yeah I think well I think you
guys have you're probably sensitive to
that because you guys have had some
dreams come true
yeah and it's always a fun it's a bit of
a weird experience because you're like
this is what I always dreamt of which is
not quite the same thing as I'm so happy
it's it's it's similar but it's not
quite the same thing I a lot of this
isn't what I dreamt of for the record
like okay I never I from a long long
time ago starting in maybe like 2008 I
would say to Hank like I really do not
want to become widely known because I
think that would be I think it would
wouldn't be fun I started you know you
get a glimpse of proper celebrity and
you see how it can be destructive and
how it can be so disruptive in people's
lives especially their family lives and
so I was very wary of that
that's why we've never done a TV made a
TV do or anything like that
because you guys can attest to how
famous TV will make you oh yeah
especially when you're on that IFC no no
no that's in like 20,000 homes now oh
yeah like the population of Fuquay
Varina I mean I wouldn't categorize it
as a setback it was a great experience
but yeah it was I mean it sometimes I
feel like it was in terms of what I was
what we want to do and accomplishing
where we are it's the kind of thing that
you enjoy it's like when you go on an
incredible trip somewhere that's kind of
challenging but exciting and got a
there's all these new experiences I
think it's very difficult for people to
enjoy it in the moment but you enjoy it
and the pictures and the memories right
it's just you have you have you thought
about that actively throughout this
process like I want to stop and enjoy
this yeah yeah I've tried to stop and
enjoy it a lot and I've been lucky that
things have been so enjoyable you know
that it hasn't been stressful or more
needlessly stressful at least like you
know that I haven't had to go around and
pitch a movie I don't like wait right is
what most authors have to do and that
that's not nearly as fun but yeah I've
really I have taken time to enjoy but I
think that I will enjoy the pictures
more you know like I think inevitably
looking back on something you can look
back on it with such unambiguous
fondness because you're not tired
anymore you're not stressed out anymore
yeah you're not thinking about when you
have to get up in the morning or the
fact that your stomach hurts anymore
you're just really enjoying it so I'm
okay with that
I've always been like I don't know
there's something about being a novelist
it makes my whole life oriented toward
the past a little bit like I like having
written a lot more than I like writing
you know I like I like looking back on
on on a writing experience a lot more
than I like being in it so I don't mind
enjoying things in retrospect right now
and you know there is this romanticized
version of the life of an author right I
picture you in a cabin somewhere with no
and there's no electricity you're
writing like a Gandalf typewriter by the
like a lamp oil you're smoking a pipe
yeah you know I think everybody has this
this this picture is like okay well now
you've reached that level right okay
you've got this the smashing success now
we're all gonna read the next thing that
you write but we all know that you
there's a lot of other facets right so
there's so many other things that you're
involved in and you haven't slowed down
any of that stuff so is there this
temptation now it's just like oh yeah I
could do that I could go spend a week
with a crazy woman somewhere and she
might hold me hostage for a while I feel
like a lot of your understanding of
being a novelist comes from misery yeah
I do worry about I do
Kathy Bates coming in my cabin that's
why the cabin not worth the risk of
Kathy Bates showing up um no like I
write in a Starbucks the same Starbucks
for a long time yeah I I don't know I
want to keep doing all the stuff that we
do i mean i-i i do want to write another
novel at some point i like writing books
i like being inside of a story but i
really love crash course and
vlogbrothers and
I love the art assignment like that
stuff I'm really passionate about that
stuff and and it's right in front of you
there's a fulfillment y'all know this
like there's a fulfillment to doing
something that goes up in a week or in a
few days as opposed to doing something
that takes you know six months of work
and then it's out and then you know then
there's always sort of that like
postpartum depression of the doubt and
no God and I think we experience the
fear sometimes of never creating that
big thing so I mean we we look to you as
an inspiration to okay
in the midst of all the things that
you're creating and you and Hank are
working on that you're you're you've
written and you you will continue to
write and create that thing that
requires the investment and then it's
gonna take right a year or years to put
it together right I mean that is that is
agile and fascinating right yeah like
how do you stay disciplined even when
you have other work you know and when
your other work is quite a little yeah
yeah it's doing well and like there is
that there is that challenge for me
though they're so separate like the
passion that I feel for writing is so
different than the than my like interest
in online video because it's one one
part of me that wants to like be in my
basement you know 12 or 14 hours a day
and then there is another part of me
that's really started to like
collaboration as crash-course and the
other things have grown to involve teams
I really like that you know I like
working with smart interesting people
who kind of keep me a little bit young
and helped me to think think more
broadly about stuff than I otherwise
would if I was stuck inside my own head
so I'm hopeful that I can find a way to
kind of chart the middle path even if it
means that there's a little bit less
crash course in a little bit and a
little bit longer between novels that I
can still stay involved in both yeah I
would say that you're probably you @un
Hank some of the least materialistic
people that you know I know but we all
know that I mean that there's been some
financial success with what's happening
with The Fault in Our Stars yeah have
you splurged on anything yeah yeah I
bought my dream car a year after the
fall nurse stars came out on the
one-year anniversary
brand-new cyber metallic gray Chevy Volt
five five years of desperately wanting a
Chevy Volt and got rid of her station
wagon and got this Chevy Volt and it's
so from zero to 20 it's just the fastest
car in the world it's all torque it's
like driving it's super fast
all right golf cart in the world great
but it goes 80 it's like a golf cart
that goes 80 so fun to drive man it's
all--it's it handles so great so yeah I
got it I got a volt and then there's a
lot of rednecks where we're from that
have golf carts and lawn mowers
definitely gas-powered we did that and
then you know we did I don't know we go
what we go on nice vacations and stuff
but no we don't mean you know Sarah and
I don't have any particularly I mean we
like we like art we like books but we
don't have any particularly ambitious
non philanthropic plans right has the
success of the book and the movie
created an imbalance in the vlogbrothers
so I think a little bit that's a great
question you guys you guys man it's
always good that's why I like that's why
I like this podcast that's an
interesting question it it hasn't
because Hank doesn't care about material
success at all but it has in the sense
that there are all these people watching
our videos who maybe don't identify as
closely with nerdfighteria as we're used
to and so they don't identify as people
who are interested in nerdfighter
projects and who are you know kind of
equally interested in both of our work
that's always been the hallmark of the
vlogbrothers channel is that like there
was never any competition Hank and I
never fought that's pretty rare for a
two-person collaborative I mean you guys
have been very lucky and Hank and I have
been very lucky but I think a lot of
times it gets it gets weird at some
point
but we were very conscious of that going
into the movie and so I feel like now
that the movie is you were conscious of
it was there a conversation yeah yeah
yeah we had several conversations where
we talked about what we were gonna do
about kind of the influx of fans who
maybe aren't nerdfighters and I think we
both felt like some of them will become
nerdfighters which is amazing and some
of them will go on and like other stuff
which is good too and we've just been
trying to stay true to that and to make
you know - in this whole process as far
as possible to make videos that are for
nerdfighters and hopefully we've been
doing a pretty good job of that so that
the people who are really interested in
the community and the project based
stuff will stay into it well it's
interesting you seem to be the answer
seems to be very much focused on the
audience and well but there's the
psychology of it in within your mind
with in Hanks mind you know I know for
for me and well I'll just speak for
myself I won't speak for Rhett but
there's a thing in a partnership where
at least for me there's a question in my
mind of am i contributing enough hmm you
know it's it's not am i the favorite in
enough people's minds you know are half
the tweets who say so-and-so's my
favorite are just or me everyday no but
that okay am i and I want to be an equal
contributor here right and that's
something that goes through my mind
there's a psychology to that that well
this is probably a good time for me to
tell you that I'm working on a book
about two teenagers if that goes well
that sounds like a terrible commercial I
that'll never work
yeah no I guess I guess for us we don't
really feel that or I don't feel that
way because I'm conscious of what I'm
contributing I'm also extremely
conscious of what Hank is contributing I
mean Hank works tirelessly more than any
other person I know and so I never worry
if Hank is I mean he may worry if I'm
pulling my weight I'm sure he does
sometimes but I certainly never worry if
he's pulling his because he just um
he is absolutely indefatigable when it
comes to finding new stuff to do finding
new stuff to share finding new ways to
make educational material like he just
he has no quit in him and so no I I feel
like we contribute very different things
and that's been a lot of the strength of
it as me knowing what's mine and him
knowing once his you know I think that's
a that's definitely a part of the
maturation process of a duo yeah you
know we're a lot more like brothers than
we are friends in a lot of ways right we
known each other for so long but yeah I
think a big part even though the past a
decade it's like specialization between
the two of us and you're kind of like oh
yeah you know and when when link takes
this it's better when I take this mm-hmm
element of it the final product ends up
being better I think that's a it's been
a big right big thing for you got to
learn it you got to learn to trust each
other
um even when you don't necessarily agree
if it's someone else's but I'm like well
that's Hanks thing so yeah we look for
their strengths yeah his strengths right
exactly
got it yeah now were you guys I've read
that you guys weren't close as kids no
we really weren't I mean well we in the
sense that we were the you know it was
just the two of us so we were we were
kind of close just because we lived in
the same house all the time two years
three years of our three years apart and
then but I went to boarding school when
he was 11 I was 14 and he was 11 so I
didn't know him past childhood you know
and then we didn't really we we we liked
each other a lot I think we had great
admiration for each other and for I had
a lot of admiration for the work that
Hank was doing back you know after he
graduated from school but I didn't know
him well until vlogbrothers
and now of course I know I mean I know
him arguably too well right okay so I
want to I'll get back to Brotherhood 2.0
but just to kind of you know when you
went off to boarding school and then
from there what was what was life like
for you there I mean that's it was great
I mean I went to this weird very
progressive boarding school in Alabama
that was responsibility oriented so
unless you did something to get your
privileges revoked you had a lot of
freedom and was co-ed and it was very
open and liberal and everything that you
don't picture when you picture
rural Alabama and why did you go there
well I was a kind of a terrible student
that was reason one and then also I had
a lot of social problems and my cousin's
had gone there a couple of my cousin's
had gone there and so I really wanted to
because I thought my cousin's were cool
and I also just wanted to start over I
wanted a place where people hadn't known
me for as this like massive nerd you
know for my whole life and so this was a
chance to start over of course it turns
out that you take your nerdiness with
you you picked up right where you left
off
yeah it wasn't much better I mean it was
better in the sense that nerdiness was
celebrated at Indian spring so I quickly
found a group of friends and um and I
became you know by the end of school
there were only 52 people in our
graduating class there wasn't a ton of
room for cliques and I really I was
lucky too that was the place where I
made my first real deep school
friendships you know I'd had two best
friends growing up but they hadn't been
in the same grade as me so that that
connection of like school to life was
just complete because we were never off
campus unless we were together so there
was an intimacy to it that I think most
people associate with college that I
kind of had in high school and so that
was perfect fodder for a book yeah yeah
and a lot of Looking for Alaska comes my
first novel comes from that time you
know living with a bunch of young people
together with sort of minimal adult
supervision now were you writing at that
time yeah I like to write a lot I wasn't
very good but I wrote for fun as well as
for school so I did writing was really
the only I guess like productive
extracurricular activity I had the only
thing that I did that wasn't bad for me
and I was lucky to be surrounded by
really good writers in high school I had
I had good teachers but I also had
classmates who were in in retrospect
really really great writers some of whom
went on to be published like Daniel
Allen but some of whom didn't but it was
great it was a great environment to to
think about writing because there were
so many people reading so much in
writing so much and having lots of
conversations about it why are you guys
in Alabama what were your parents doing
there well I lived my
we're still living in Florida at the
time my dad is directed the nature
conservancy down there for a long long
time and I was um yeah so we we just
moved to basically moved to I moved to
Alabama and they stayed in Florida okay
and then when you went to college you
studied early Islamic history yeah yeah
so that was that the name of the major
no I was a religion major but my my area
of academic interest I guess was early
Islamic history so that's what I wrote
all my papers about so what what goes
into that I mean that in in terms of the
choice motivation
well I took one class in I took a intro
to religion class and I took kind of an
intro to Islam class and which is really
interesting to me that there was this
you know there was this worldview that a
billion people shared that I knew
basically nothing about I mean this was
in the late 1990s so Islam wasn't really
part of the cultural conversation in the
United States and so I just I just
became really interested in it and I
wanted to learn a lot about it I wanted
to learn especially a lot about kind of
the emergence of Islam and how it spread
I've always been interested in how ideas
spread and we like to imagine really
simplistic ways of ideas spreading but
it's really really complicated so we
always think that Islam spread by the
sword for instance with the growth of
the Arab Empire but in fact like it's
much more complicated than that in a lot
of times the conversion the conversion
happened without any kind of war or
battle or anything but the reasons why
it happened were equally complicated so
I just found that really interesting in
my thinking about you know how do I have
an idea that gets inside of someone
else's head and then how do we have
ideas that get inside of millions of
people's heads that was a very early but
kind of modern example of it because it
happened and you know like 622 CE II so
this is what your biscuits listeners
come for oh yeah but so it sounds like
you came at a religion major from an
academic perspective was there a
personal faith perspective because you
wanted to be a priest too right yeah
there was I mean I'm not a Muslim but
but I'm a
companion but I did I was really
interested in in religion and my
interest in becoming an Episcopal priest
was not primarily looking back like
about my personal faith it was about my
like interest in theological questions
and in questions of meaning and
suffering and and thinking that that
would be a good place to have those
conversations like thinking that the
church for me growing up and especially
in college was a place to have those
conversations about suffering and about
hope and whether there was any meaning
in human life and that was a biscuit
belly in your yeah you're still
Episcopalian yeah like growing up with
your parents or like they were they were
method it's all the same though when
it's that like sort of you know
lefty/lefty protestant stuff it's pretty
interchangeable I shouldn't say that as
an Episcopalian no the only the benefit
of being Episcopalian is you get to
kneel more I'm a big fan of kneeling and
crossing myself you can get to heart do
that hardly at all as a Methodist so
that was the number one draw for me well
that sounds like a joke but there may be
some you know I like really I like I
like the sort of I like ritual and I
like rituals that that pull me back
through history you know that that
connect me to people who lived 1800
years ago or whatever and I know that I
mean you you've said this a number of
times in other interviews how that
wanting to become a priest you ended up
becoming a student chaplain yeah in a
Children's Hospital yeah that was kind
of the beginning of the the story of
Fault in Our Stars yeah that's where it
that's where I started trying to write
it right after I worked at the hospital
I worked there for about six months
you know it was a weird job because I
was a student chaplain but when I was on
call they were no other chaplains in the
hospital so I was the only person that
if someone died if a baby was going to
die and needed to be baptized I was the
only person there to baptize the baby
and or if someone died I was there with
the family when as they went through
that process but also you know if there
was any kind of trauma part of the a
chaplain
always part of the trauma team so the
the chaplain and the social worker
usually are stay with the family you
know through the emergency department
and the process of getting admitted to
the hospital so what is the experience
of being that close to dying children
what kind of impact does that have on
your faith pretty severe one positive I
would no no no I mean you know I had a
lot of I had a lot of ideas about why
theologically sound I think ideas about
why good you know good people have
horrible things happen to them about why
suffering exists and why it's unjustly
distributed and all that stuff the
problem that Christians call theodicy
the problem of evil you know in a world
where God is good and powerful but all
of my ideas about it proved kind of
useless you know I mean I could I could
I could say that those things were
intellectually true I just didn't care
because you know I was face to face with
the randomness arbitrariness of human
existence and the idea that this stuff
was happening for a reason seemed very
problematic to me now that didn't
destroy my faith and I still go to
church and it's still an important part
of my life it did make me think that I
shouldn't be working from inside the
church like I shouldn't be doing this
work from inside the church because I
just didn't have the the right kind of
DNA for it you know also I couldn't do
it like I mean after a good a good
chaplain or social worker anyone who
works in a Children's Hospital really
has the ability to do this incredibly
difficult work this emotionally
wrenching work to be fully present to be
fully there for the people who need you
and then to go home and be fully there
for your family and for the for the
people in your non-professional life and
I did not have that ability at all so
you know I kind of learned that about
myself and that's a good thing to know
and I still really
I have great I have great affection for
chaplains whenever I am in the hospital
I'm always like bring me the jab
I want to I want to hang out with you
everybody whoever's on call tonight so
Carson Daly couldn't do it either yeah
priest so you should connect with him so
did you and do you find satisfactory
answers to those questions that you're
kind of faced with when you when you see
children going through that kind of
suffering do you find that in your faith
um I do I do
to an extent I don't I don't as
completely and without reservation as
many of the people I know and many of
the people I admire both intellectually
and in the way they go about their lives
I just um I'm I'm okay I guess I guess
for me like I'm okay living in a world
that's arbitrary and random and unfair I
need to know the kind of world I'm
living in in order to be happy and I
need to I need to try to orient as much
of my work toward injustice or and
inequality as possible because otherwise
because that's what that's what makes me
feel meaning you know and that's true
that's true in in the church like the
stuff the stuff that gets me most
excited about being a member of my
church is about service and connection
more than it's about any kind of
evangelism or direct evangelism or
whatever and the stuff that the stuff
that gets me going and in my
professional life is about you know the
project for awesome or building a school
in Bangladesh or whatever like that if
it's a lot more interesting to me than
how many subscribers we have right well
not in that you know brings up another
thing which is obviously Hank is
involved in all those things and seems
very much equally motivated but as far
as I understand he doesn't share your
faith no yeah no right well I don't know
if he'd identify as an atheist but he
wouldn't identify he'd identify as close
oh I don't know I don't we don't talk
about that stuff that much mostly
because our worldviews are turned in the
same direction yes so like what we want
to do on a daily basis has turned in the
same direction
it's kind of two ways of imagining
meaning to life one way is that like we
as human beings constructed we make it
up as we go along and another is that we
derive it we derive it from some
organizing principle to the universe or
some source scripture or whatever it is
and in the end I don't know if I care if
meaning is constructed or derived as
long as like the people I'm working
closest with are turned in the same
direction like the meaning that they
find is similar so it Orient's us
similarly and that with Hank I mean
we're pretty much a hundred percent on
the same page all the time like we never
one thing we never argue about is like
purpose so that's that's good because
that's a pretty core argument if you end
up having it you know right yes that's
so fascinating I I guess I'd like to go
to the Brotherhood 2.0 because that kind
of it sounds like that defines your
friendship you know it's what you just
said is like a real testimony to the
fact that even though you guys may
become you have beliefs that are rooted
in different places that you're so
aligned when it comes to what you guys
are accomplishing together as a team
it's it it's it's amazing having not
been close as kids was the whole
Brotherhood thing was that Brotherhood
2.0 but was that his idea it was my idea
your idea yeah I was a big fan well we
were both big friends as a Frank and the
show was a Frank and it's I'm I I didn't
think that because the first video was
like yeah but then the second video your
first one the first thing out of your
mouth is I'm not gonna be good at this
to me it seemed like you were saying I
don't know if this is a great idea but
I'll do it
it was my idea was not gonna be show her
face but my idea but I have to say that
if Hank hadn't gotten enthusiastic about
it it never would have happened so I was
like we should do a collaborative video
blog that's like the show but you only
have half as much work because you're
talking to each other and plus then we
could stop textual e communicating and
start like talking to each other every
day which we hadn't done really because
we only talked over text so was the day
show done
that point no it was it was it has to go
it had three months to go but everyone
knew it was going to end and so we were
kind of thinking about the future in how
sad we would be and yeah I mean if Hank
I had the idea but then if Hank hadn't
been like yes let's do that let's here's
how here's where you go get a camera
here's the camera that you get here's
how you edit video I mean you know he
I'd never made a video before I'd never
owned a camcorder before so it was and
you didn't believe you could do it
that's the first words out of your mouth
no I thought I'd be terrible and to be
fair I was I was terrible for many
months I was you go back and you watch
those old videos and I find them just
crushing crushingly slow well you caught
it in that first video you referred to
the endeavor as a documentary yeah no
that's what I thought it was gonna be do
it I was imagining it right yeah but it
is not I mean maybe it is it's kind of a
it's it's kind of it's a document of our
of our lives over many many years which
is something I'm gonna be so grateful to
have and I think I think that our you
know my kids will be so grateful I hope
you know to have but but you know almost
from the beginning we saw it as a
project with an audience and an audience
that we had to engage with and that
doing stuff even if it was only a couple
hundred people doing stuff with those
two hundred people was gonna be a lot
cooler than anything that we could do
just with each other like just talking
to each other was not going to be as
interesting as actively engaging the
people watching it so you you I'm
assuming you got some of that the idea
of an audience and all right just almost
creating a movement with a way that is a
kind of dealt with that everyone who was
involved in all the ideas that he had
absolutely so when you started you had
that in mind like this is a this is
community building well I think maybe
for the first two weeks we didn't think
of it that way but we started to think
of it as community building very quickly
I think the first time that we really
understood that there was a community
around the videos we only had maybe 300
regular viewers and I had to be
hospitalized because I had this very
rare weird infection behind my eye that
wasn't serious but like you had to get
IV antibiotics and to cheer me up the
Hank asked people to put something on
their heads because that had become an
inside joke somehow
and we had like 300 viewers and we got
like 240 pictures and I was like oh my
gosh that is I mean percentage right can
you imagine a straight about like that
today I mean it's just unimaginable so
it was a different time a different
world but yeah it was
that's when we realized oh my gosh like
we should probably do something other
than just have people put stuff on their
heads well and because of that you're I
got fixed yeah it did work look look at
me now still - I pretty awesome well I
mean I could definitely say that when we
decided that oh we needed we needed to
name our community we need to cut we
need to do this it was definitely
looking at you guys and thinking oh look
what they've done here they've created
they're not creating content only there
they're building a movement and there
they're accomplishing so many things and
they and they see the potential in that
community I mean what was that process
like obviously you just kind of revealed
that first initial realization of how
they could be motivated to do something
but when did you start thinking about
this is a strategic community I mean
here we are at VidCon right it's kind of
seeing the culmination of that but
what's that process like I think you
know we never we never wanted to think
of the community just as like a
launching pad for other ideas like we
wanted it to live to have its own life
and to have its own meaning but you know
I think VidCon was really the first
thing that emerged out of nerdfighteria
that became much different from
nerdfighteria and much larger and you
know it really it came of a hank's
feeling that we needed a conference and
that he knew a lot of people who made
youtube videos and so he should just do
the conference and I thought that was a
terrible idea I thought it would make
people who made YouTube videos hate us
and that if the conference was bad it
would be the end of our careers also
it's very expensive so we essentially
like had our houses against the
conference I just I thought it was a bad
idea but I did know by then that I have
to trust Hank when he has an idea if he
sticks with it for more than like six
hours it's usually something that he's
going to do whether I like it or not so
I better I better get behind him
and then of course you know VidCon
turned out to be amazing and then from
there we did start to launch channels
that are kind of outgrowths of their
nerdfighter area but are separate from
it like crash course or scishow or the
art assignment and we've done that I
still think of that as an extension a
way of kind of like building small
groups within a big group because it's
really problematic when a community
becomes so large that it's unwieldy that
people it's hard for people to think of
themselves as you know as nerdfighters
if what's a nerdfighter if everyone's a
nerdfighter yeah and so we want there to
be communities within the community
whether it's the minecraft server or the
people who like to watch me play FIFA or
the people who are passionate about the
art assignment whatever it is like
that's really important I think to the
future too like making it work making it
sustainable so that people are still
still feel involved enough to want to be
want to do stuff with us well yeah I
think about the fact that it doesn't
goes back to the question that we asked
earlier was does the success of the book
in the movie is it upsetting the balance
of the vlogbrothers but it also
potentially creates this sense that your
community is built on so many different
things that you guys have done over time
and then to have something that is this
landmark achievement in a real
traditional sense almost have you
thought about how that might threaten
the community yeah I mean it's been a
big concern for us is how do we sort of
like you know kind of build a seawall
against the rising tide of The Fault in
Our Stars so that it doesn't become a
moment that we all look back on and say
like oh it was all magical until then um
and you know my our main strategy for
that like the first video I made after
after The Fault in Our Stars came out
was devoted almost entirely to the book
that we're reading this summer for the
nerdfighter book club about living in a
slum in Mumbai
and I just was basically I did that
partly as a way of saying like okay well
now back to normal Frank you know like
now now back to talking about stuff that
we care about with people we care about
and and you know like it being
being a fan of the vlogbrothers means a
lot of this you know for better I hope
you like this but this is what it is
instead of trying to orient ourselves to
the most possible viewers I think that
and that in that respect we've taken
inspiration from you guys because you
were very conscious about choose kind of
choosing community over virality at some
point and and using virality as a way to
build a community instead of using
community as a way to build virality and
that's I I thought that was really smart
and it also like it also made me like
more of a fan if that makes sense like
it made me more interested in your work
instead of it just being like oh I know
I can go there to see a funny video it
was like oh I like those people it can
hang out yeah I mean we didn't know with
good mythical morning that it would
become what it has but we're very glad
because we it's based on our friendship
and it's based on you know who what we
want to talk about and letting people in
in that conversation you know the us
that is not just the two of you guys but
as your entire community is something
that we we constantly kind of check
against to control okay what is our us
is it just the two of us or is it also
our fans a mythical beast kind of a
thing yeah what was a milestone early on
that kind of bumped up vlogbrothers from
I mean you knew pretty early on you had
an audience yeah but I mean it was tiny
but you weren't very early you were
talking to that you would you would
always talk to each other you still do
yeah but you're not really you know
everybody yeah you just have this like
innate way to address each other in the
right moments of your vlogs but then
you're talking to everyone it's it's an
interesting talent yeah that's a weird
balance when I first started that no one
else really has to do I don't know what
else has to say good morning Hank it's
Tuesday
yeah I've said like I've said good
morning Hank it's Tuesday on something
like like 250 consecutive Tuesdays and
when you say hey you're you are used are
you still thinking Hank are you thinking
everybody but I just say hey I just
I call them Hank you know I I really I
do still think Hank and I still think
that Hank is the first and most
important member of my audience but I'm
very conscious that it's not just Hank
and there are lots of times that Hank
knows something that I have to tell
everyone so in that case I try not to
say Hank in that case I try to try to
come out of that like idea that it's
just an open letter to Hank and be like
hey nerdfighters Hank knows this but
Hank has a concert on Wednesday what was
the philip defranco milestone you know
we had a few milestones the first one
and the first big bump was back in the
days of featured YouTube videos okay
yeah Hank had a video that was featured
about the last Harry Potter book coming
out he had he sang a song about it and
that suddenly we went from 200
subscribers to 7,000 almost overnight
and then along the way there were a lot
of other bumps there was a huge series
of bumps really from Phil where Phil
would talk about the vlogbrothers how
much you liked the vlogbrothers one time
I think the first time in a video intro
he referenced us you know he had that
old video intro where he would be and he
was was very very say Frank sounding
yeah I'm back in 2007 as were we yeah
and and he mentioned the vlogbrothers
and we got another several thousand
subscribers then but it was you know
YouTube still I think but especially
then for us was really about youtubers
helping youtubers there was very little
at least in my memory there was very
little of anybody trying to take anyone
else's audience and a lot of trying to
expand the overall size of the pie which
was really it was it was a good yeah it
was a good era in YouTube history it
felt like we were Hollywood before the
studio's the studio system came in you
know like Hollywood in the teens where
we were kind of making up the rules as
we went along and what we were doing was
accidentally important to the future you
know it shaped the future we just didn't
know it at the time and of course I
think more than anyone's a did that say
by inventing the idea that
online video projects could be community
oriented and then also by inventing most
of the conventions of the vlogging genre
which he had no idea he was doing at the
time of course right it's amazing it's
amazing it how like you said how much
feel sounded like everyone in 2007
sounded like Phil if they're logging
yeah right Annie and he said that yeah
now he also promoted the book was that
Paper Towns Paper Towns yeah paper he
promoted Paper Towns
when it came out as you know he was
gonna do that and what happened I didn't
know he was gonna do it and it was
responsible for it being on the
bestseller list the second week I mean I
think the first week that it was on it
was nerdfighters and then he kind of got
it on for a second week just by talking
about it and saying he liked it and then
it held on for a third week and then it
fell off and I thought that was about as
good as book sales would ever be would
ever be I mean that was amazing to me
the idea that my book could make the New
York Times bestseller list was just for
any bearded son yeah I was crazy I mean
I could never have imagined that I
certainly never thought about that when
I was writing it I mean never occurred
to me that it would be a book with that
kind of audience well and you pointed
out in a you know an a tumblr post that
a lot of people have assumed oh well
this is this was this book was popular
at The Fault in Our Stars because of
your YouTube career but you've explained
hey I had three out four books already
out there right and they would make it
to the the bestsellers list because of
nerdfighteria then they would fall off
in this in this one how many weeks was
it at number one it's still there yeah
and how many weeks weeks you're talking
now 130
I mean insanity yeah but you say you
kind of outlined the reasons why and
it's you know it's it's is things beyond
well it's actually kind of simple I'll
let you yeah it is things beyond there
and fight area that said it never would
have happened without nerdfighteria
right if I hadn't had this audience it
never would have happened because the
the the initial activation energy never
would have been there I mean we sold
80,000 books in the first week and that
was entirely because it were released
primarily because of nerdfighter I mean
I'd like to think that I had some people
who just like my books but let's face it
not that many I mean you had you
committed to signing every
pre-sold yeah which turned out to be
150,000 150,000 that you signed I did
and did did Hank also sign the book Hank
put little Hank or fishes in 5% of them
which was still a huge undertaking I
mean that's a lot of the smaller books
it was it was a few hundred all 150k I
did indeed and so so obviously that's
nice I don't know how that's possible
that you actually did that I don't
believe that you did but it's okay
machine on the standard stamps I did it
took two months it was really enjoyable
I might do it again just because I found
it so relaxing like I know this like our
work can be very stressful and like on
some on some level you're never not
working but when I was during those two
months I was signing like people would
call and I would be like I'm sorry I
have to sign a hundred fifty thousand
sheets of paper so I cannot I will have
to talk about this later
it's a different kind of writing you
know but I mean the point is yes without
nerdfighteria it wouldn't have had this
huge bump before anybody could even read
it right it had that initial energy but
the reason that the book has hung around
is I mean it's partly that people like
it it has very good Goodreads ratings
much better than any of my other books
so I think people have responded to it
generously and then I think it's also
partly that you know this is
underappreciated by us on the internet
but the the IRL people worked IRL hard
to sell a lot of IRL books so I think
you know I had an amazing amazing and
still do amazing sales team around that
book and penguin just believed that they
could force it down people's throats and
if they forced it down enough people's
throats that it would catch on by word
of mouth and that's what they didn't I
mean it was it it was a great book it is
a great book and it's just a confluence
of everything working correctly I think
that's what you said at the beginning
yes and then so now you've cursed I who
knows how many different industry
with the expectation you know people in
suits and all types of industries are
now expecting their thought they're
throwing you around it's so many rooms
if you if you got oh if you've got a
website or a YouTube channel
unless you've got yet get that DeFranco
got to mention your 3 years earlier and
then okay and what else in it you know
it right right they will they all in
Hollywood they all think it was because
of my Twitter know about YouTube in
Hollywood you know they're just like man
he has a lot of Twitter followers he
must have told them to go to the movie
and they must have gone right and I'm
like wow they want to boy that down
you're right it was Twitter the
inescapable truth is none of it works if
it if it's not good yeah so it also has
to be authentic like yeah it you know
you have to really genuinely want to
talk about something and want to connect
you know it can't just be about a desire
to oh like this is a way to get rich
like it's it's at first off it's a
terrible terrible way to get rich and
it's just not if you want to get rich
like go move the big pile of money
around and try to make it bigger like
that's the way to get rich like this
this has to be about a desire to to
genuinely connect with people and to
have real conversations that matter to
you
and if it's not then I think it never
works and it's interesting because at
this point you know if I zoned out for a
second which I didn't and came back to
your statement I wouldn't know if you
were talking about which you know The
Fault in Our Stars or the vlog brothers
or any other any other project because
that is the cornerstone of all of it is
the authenticity and you know you're not
you're not just looking to move a big
pile of money around no no you have to
want it you have to want to do something
but I think most people do deep down I
think most people I don't think people
really I think most people want to do
work that matters and there's lots and
lots of ways of doing that I mean and it
doesn't it for many people it for most
people it doesn't get to be their
profession you know so but I'm always
you know I'm always amazed by by people
who aren't defined by their profession
in the way that I am you know who just
go out and do volunteer work and it's
just something that they're very
passionate about and
they find a lot of fulfillment there but
you have to if you're not guided by that
that you know that desire to make a
difference in people's lives and to try
then I think you get off path really
really quickly it's it's really hard to
stay focused on that but if you get off
that path it goes to all bad places well
let me ask then I think we've pinpointed
your passion what makes you angry astons
lack of nuance in conversations that
sort of that I that idea that things
simply are simply aren't or that you
know whether it's about history or or
religion or all of the things that that
the internet fights about if we're not
seeing it nuanced if we're not if we're
not trying to understand another
person's narrative you mean the gray the
gray areas of life all the gray spaces
are really fascinating to me and I
wanted that Liam Neeson movie yeah it's
a little dark in the plane he want to
talk about being angry he's very angry
yeah he's always after somebody yeah II
am Neeson as he needs to get revenge so
yeah I I do think that uh yeah I think I
for me at least that's the that's the
thing that makes me mad is we always
counter this I mean you see it a lot on
the internet I think when people people
make sort of bold statements that that
are easily reblog allure that or that
look you know are sort of the the
internet version of a bumper sticker you
can't I don't think you can get to the I
don't think you can get to the capital T
truth but via the internet version of a
bumper sticker I think you have to have
nuanced conversations and complex
conversations about complex ideas that
that that are open to the idea that you
might be wrong or that you you want to
have your thinking further clarified
instead of coming into it you know
wanting to shout the unassailable truth
that you know to be true and that's a
frustration for me on the internet
because I want to stay I want us to have
a really high quality of discourse so
like I see that a lot in in YouTube
comments nerdfighteria is incredibly
blessed in this respect the comments on
our videos are amazing
but even on crash course comments it
often quickly descends into fighting
about the gold standard or whatever
right well it's interesting because
there is a large level of irony in the
fact that you're in very eloquent guy
you speak eloquently you write
eloquently your characters speak in ways
that most teenagers that I know don't
speak you know and they don't speak any
in any way that is reflective of YouTube
comments it'd be great to write a novel
it's okay here's an idea for you guys
maybe we could work together on this
write a novel
that's just YouTube comments or you try
to construct a narrative you know like
it's it's one person is really mad we
thought we've got an idea based on
YouTube comments the audios up oh that's
easy but you know I thought about that
now it's one of the observations that my
wife made as she was reading the book
was that she's liked the way they speak
to each other it's it's almost like
you're calling people to a higher level
of discourse is that intentional or is
that just how you want your characters
to come across or I mean I do I want
them to I'm more interested in them
sounding like we feel like we sound yeah
we always feel like we sound pretty
smart you know but then when you
actually diagram the things that we say
it's completely under gravel like the
sentence I'm sure it's not a sentence in
any way I hate reading my interviews you
know God when people just they just
write down what you say I make it into a
sentence you know what I mean it's like
I'm a sixth grader in every single
interviews all the time do I cut through
my sentences but yeah I I I do want to
I'm interested I like I like writing
about people who are really openly
enthusiastically engaged and not not
terribly embarrassed about it and I
think those people it in their best
moments like do have do have
conversations at least that feel that
way but particularly The Fault in Our
Stars
I was also conscious that I was writing
in this genre of the star-crossed lover
and that genre is defined by it's sort
of purple prose you know like the fact
that Romeo and Juliet's first 12 lines
back in four
to each other form a sonnet like people
don't talk like that but it's it's
always been part of the way that we
think about kind of cursed romance so I
wanted to I wanted to use it but
hopefully also undercut it at times
particularly in the second half of the
book right well I what I wanted to ask
just to get back to you and Hank
so are you guys best friends what mean
what the whole process over the years
since Brotherhood 2.0 and it sounds like
beginning your friendship yeah really
why was that the beginning of your
friendship and characterize it now it
was the beginning of our friendship as
adults on equal footing for sure or at
least it was a dramatic change you know
where we became really really close yeah
I definitely think that I mean I have a
I have a best friend in India am place
who I see every day and who like you
know like essentially they they
co-parent our kids and we co-parent
theirs and my friend Chris okay you
don't know him okay he might come to
VidCon someday what is it what does he
do he works he owns an interpreting
company he does medical and legal
interpreting it's really cool actually
he works with with a huge Burmese
community in Indianapolis a lot of
Burmese people settled in Indianapolis
in the last 20 years and he works with
that community to make sure that people
you know when they're in the hospital or
whatever can have kind of high quality
conversations with their doctors right
providing good interpreters that's
difficult anyways I know right yeah even
if you can't speak the language I
struggle with it look I lied to my
doctor about how I hurt my shoulder but
yeah so but Hank and I I mean Hank and I
are best friends and we are well you
know you can only have one oh yes there
is that Hank I mean Hank is my brother
we are we are super tight brothers okay
we could not be closer as brothers also
I think my wife is probably my best
friend okay yes I could have really
thrown you under the bus I'm glad you
yeah
so what yeah but you crawled out yeah
but yeah I she lifted her third butt
okay I have seven best friends now now
that I think of it ya know
Hank and I Hank and our
so close that it doesn't seem I mean
we're like I can't imagine working
without him I can't imagine I wouldn't
be interested in doing things if it
weren't for collaborating with Hank is
the nature of your your conversations do
they are they ever like friends or is it
because you're business partners - yeah
I mean we do that nice so much about
conversations are just about our
collaborative business endeavors and
that defines our friendship but I don't
even know if that's a I mean that
there's pitfalls associated with that
but it's not necessarily a bad thing I
don't think it's bad I you know I need
shared projects to talk to Hank about
because otherwise I don't know what to
talk about and not just to him but to
anyone I don't like I'm not I don't know
I don't know how to have like a
conversation about nothing and Hank and
I III think Hank doesn't doesn't either
and so this gives us something to talk
about it gives us something to do
together it's like you know if I always
think it could it could have been model
planes you know it could have been that
I build the model planes and Hank paints
them but you said model planes
I'm really into the I'm I'm fascinated
by people who like devote their lives to
model play in their model cars or
whatever like people who really are
really passionate and like they get I
think maybe as big as this couch yeah I
know and people um other people are the
planes both come home from a linear
relationship they come home from work or
whatever and they've had a long hard day
at work and they think you know what I
would like to do to calm down I would
like to build a model plane now and I
think that's really cool and yeah so
Hank and I could collaborate on model
planes or whatever but like we need to
collaborate on something yeah in order
to stay close oh yeah there's that we
talked about it a lot there's when you
have a shared goal it's that you're
willing to work through things that if
the if the only goal was just to
maintain the friendship at some point
you'd be like okay well this is good
this got frustrating after 30 years
right right you know I mean it's almost
like a marriage yes you know it
absolutely is I think you need shared
projects in a marriage to like you need
you need things that orient you yeah
why so many people get divorced after
the kids leave because it's like you
know that's interesting well you know
we've got this project which is to get
this
kid prepared for life and then they they
leave and it's like okay we need model
planes now you have to have something
there yeah yeah you got to take care of
the the relationship as well as the
relationship with your kids which can be
challenging because kids it's easy for
kids to kind of take over a marriage
right true so what's the next model
plane if you'll forgive me I'm glad that
I introduced that to to our conversation
you know well the next thing is that we
are working with the Gates Foundation to
expand our crash course channel to
include this thing big history where we
zoom out it's really interdisciplinary
approach to studying the universe so you
begin at the beginning of the universe
and you go through the lives of people
but but by taking a sort of zoomed out
look it's a very different world of
history it includes a lot of science and
a lot of astronomy and lots of you know
lots of lots of time before people and
then even trying to imagine a time after
people what that's going to look like
with what the future looks like and
that's really cool and then we're also
I'm going I don't think I can say where
I'm going and who I'm going with
I'm going on a trip far away with
someone I really admire and I'm really
looking forward to that as an extension
of our work on global health and and
poverty and will we expect like what on
the backside of this yeah so videos on
the back side of that videos and then
also a discussion of what works in when
it comes to making life making making it
so that kids have healthier lives in the
developing world
okay so there's Oprah a campaign as well
as yeah Oprah it is Oprah I'll be going
I'll be traveling with Oprah on Oprah's
plane okay so excited it's gonna be nice
we now know that it's it's it's Stedman
I mean you've already is I'm gonna
continue to engage you you've already
mentioned gates so maybe it's Bill Gates
himself I it's it's it's not anyone as
cool as Bill Gates
but it's someone really cool oh and that
person is listening and their feelings
are hurt right now I'm sorry person but
I think we both know you're not at
school gates Oh for a second I thought
he said I'm sorry Percy and I was like
ah it's Percy guy that's sing Stand By
Me Percy Jackson sledge Percy Sister
Sledge
he's big philanthropist that's why
that's why there needs to be two of you
one to remember half of the joke and the
other room with the other there's a lot
of that that happens well you know
unfortunately because we're at VidCon we
can't have you sign the roundtable of
dim lighting but you can write on this
you could write on this table and the
Presidential Suite I'm signing it with
my mind though my mind and then next
time you're in the Burbank area you've
got to come in it and inside it yeah
absolutely yeah this has been a great
conversation thanks man thank you guys
so much and I have to say also thanks
for making stuff that I can be a fan of
lo these many years it's been great to
watch to watch you guys make so much
fascinating stuff and I really think
you're just the beginning so here's to
many more years yeah thank you thank you
we're we're honored by that sir all
right take care guys
[Music]
and there you have it our ear biscuit
with the one and only John Green you
know it's just confirmation talking to
him in the midst of all this it's just
confirmation of how great a guy he is
and how down to earth he is and how well
he's obviously seizure very smart I
think me and you together is it we're
about as smart as John Green like you
combined us and that's why we was it was
a conversation no that's why we didn't
like Hank be there Oh exactly like we're
gonna interview Hank we're not
separately at a later blog brothers at
the same time we're not that's stupid
yeah or we don't we don't want to look
that student might huh yeah it's just
it's amazing I hope you know one of the
things that we want your bisque is to be
in hope that it is is a place where you
hear a conversation that has a different
tone we talked about slightly different
things and I hope that we just haven't
regurgitated and done another typical
interview that a lot of people are gonna
do with with John but I hope that you
know I know that what I got was just
some insight into the fact that yes
the media may see this guy as the author
of The Fault in Our Stars and he is very
much that but hopefully what we've kind
of you know revealed is that he's so
much more than that not just as a person
but as an artist as a creator as a
person who is just such a voice in so
many ways to our generation really and
he sees himself in that way and it's
refreshing he hasn't just checked out
because he's had a huge success well the
fact that it was I mean yeah we're
friends like acquaintances slash friends
but we sent an email about being on air
biscuits and he was like he replied and
he was like yes you know it's like I
appreciated the fact that we were still
able to get through to the guy and he
graciously accepted our invitation it
was no different
he said I'm just sitting down with him
this VidCon was no different than
sitting down with him at last year's
VidCon right in spite of what he's
experienced and I just I personally
appreciate that no I know you probably
dude listening it's great when great
things happen to great people let John
know what you think of this ear biscuit
tweet at him it's at real John Green his
first name is actually real we didn't
talk about that that's weird but his
middle name is John and his last name is
green real John Green on Twitter hashtag
ear biscuits let him know what you
thought also rate us on iTunes you know
that's always helpful comment on
soundcloud we appreciate it yeah and
keep a look out for my new book
as I already mentioned about two people
with cancer you know what three people
with cancer screw it I'm going with
three people three teenagers still
teenagers a love triangle but they all
have cancer and I'm really hoping that
it's really gonna do well and our shames
alright guys we do this every week as
you know except next week we're taking a
one-week break from your biscuits but
rest assured the following week we will
be back with another biscuit for your
ears thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]